une circonscription qu'est-ce que c'est
et bien c'est le baptême de chez des
Juifs
[Musique]
vous connaissez le RPR oui monsieur de
quoi s'agit-il
[Musique]
les personnes
âgées-saint-léger donc Madame me montre
sa carte du RPR et il s'agit donc vous
me dit RPR ça signifie
régional région parisienne régionale le
RPR et ça ne mène pas encore à l'Hôtel
de Ville m'avez-vous dit
mais je ne crois pas vous connaissez le
PC
il avait deux tronçons le PC a d'autres
tronçons
et qui s'en allait
vers Auteuil donc si je vous comprends
bien le PC c'est la ceinture
vous connaissez l'existence du
[Musique]
rprint
alors le CRS qu'est-ce que c'est vous
avez entendu parler du CRS
non moi je suis pas CRS moi je suis une
petite bourgeoise qui vit tranquillement
le riz vous savez ce que c'est que le
Rif
pas entendu parler du RI
de quoi s'agit-il à votre avis
absolument aucune idée sur la question
si je vous dis qu'il s'agit de politique
quel nom vous verriez associer à Hery
moi je vois la république indépendante
là-dedans comment République
je le sais absolument rien un nom pour
le pour les RX ce serait quoi ce serait
pour les rires
ce serait plutôt un certain Chirac
d'Ornano
ah non non
plus
bon à mon avis ça serait qui ce serait
plutôt un sort ou un fils bain
pour les heries
si je vous dis par exemple que le CRS
c'est l'aile gauche du PS oh ben ça je
ne sais pas du tout vous ne connaissez
pas je connais pas
moi je vous parle du CRS qui est l'aile
gauche du nez de gauche du PS ça ne vous
dit rien le fait je ne sais pas du tout
je ne peux pas vous dire un PS je ne
sais pas ce que c'est j'en ai jamais
mangé on parle beaucoup en ce moment de
l'ouverture à gauche qu'en pensez-vous
ez-vous madame
je pense qu'on est habitué à s'habiller
toujours de la même façon et que c'est
un geste machinal qui doit être rapide
alors vous savez les changements sont
pas toujours tellement parfaits
qu'est-ce que c'est que le resserrement
des alliances quand ça vous gêne le
doigt
l'alliance est trop petit et que ça vous
gêne ça vous fait même mal non êtes-vous
vous-même pour le resserrement des
alliances
les dissensions intestines il y a eu pas
mal de dissensions intestines ces
derniers temps alors de quoi s'agit-il
des gargouilles qu'on a dans le ventre
c'est ça
et en politique vous imaginez
l'étendue du mandat d'un maire
entre la province et Paris les villes
au-dessus de 30000 habitants je sais que
c'est plus cher disons ça varie sur de
1 million à plusieurs mais sans compter
les pots de vin qui peuvent toucher avec
les entrepreneurs à droite et à gauche
pour les décisions qui vont une
circonscription qu'est-ce que c'est et
bien c'est du baptême de chez des Juifs
on fait je crois que c'est quelques
jours après la naissance on
coupe un petit bout de la partie le
garçon qui donne c'est le baptême des
Juifs c'est ce qu'on appelle alors le
découpage en circonscription
vous voyez ce que c'est l'ouverture à
gauche
contraire ça sera ça l'ouverture à
gauche et vous n'êtes pas spécialement
favorable je suis pas défavorable moi
vous savez une fois qu'on est habitué on
s'habitue bien
fermer nos vêtements
[Musique]